première place revient à la france
une première place pour une première
édition
[Musique]
la france championne d'europe et au sein
de l'équipe une femme stéphanie haye 30
ans tourangelle les six boucher français
ont notamment devancé leurs homologues
italien allemand espagnol dans les
épreuves cumulé de découpe de rapidité
et de présentation
trois jours après ce matin à bléré on
n'est pas peu fier l'apprend aujourd'hui
bah je trouve ça génial pour elle le
travail
voilà le travail a fait ce qu'il fallait
pour elle
stéphanie exerce dans cette boucherie
réputé en plus de son plein temps de
formatrice au cfa de jouer des tours
histoire de garder le contact avec le
monde professionnel alors ce trophée est
tout sauf anodin c'est un
accomplissement de soi même c'est c'est
une reconnaissance du travail effectué
en amont des sacrifices aussi pour le
patron des lieux où exigences et
formation sont les règles d'or le
sentiment de fierté est décuplée
stéphanie va redorer le blason de la
présence de la femme en boucherie
aujourd'hui on est un métier qui se
féminise et on s'aperçoit que on peut
très bien être femme et accéder à des
baisses des titres
aussi honorifique que peut avoir les
hommes ça parait qu anthony
cabeke de canard
fumé quoi dedans yann a fini
au cognac
c'est très bien le plaisir au quotidien
de stéphanie transmettre son savoir
échanger avec ses élèves les nourrir de
son expérience qui se conjuguent selon
les produits selon les saisons selon les
envies que la gratuité aller à l'infini
la seule la seule chose qui nous empêche
d'être créatif c'est nous c'est notre
cerveau mais en fait si vous voulez
aller par là il ya tellement de choses à
faire après c'est à nous de mettre en
place sont dit tiens j'ai une idée mais
c'est mettre en place ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne pas on recommence ou on
change qu'on associe deux d'autres
choses et de saveurs la jeune femme
continue à parfaire ses acquis en
septembre prochain auront lieu les
championnats du monde à sacramento en
californie
le rendez vous est déjà pris